Allah
[Silence]
They mean the same thing,
right? But they are used in
different places for different
reasons that we won't get into
to date inshallah. Now, when we
speak about the reasons, the
causes for a person's heart to
become open Some of them are
from Allah. Some of them are
from your actions. But
ultimately, the one who opens
your heart is Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala said,
Islam. Whoever Allah decides,
chooses to guide, he will open
his heart to Islam. So, this is
something that is a gift from
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. And
the prophet said in the
narration of Abdullah and
Ahmed. In Allah and your
doesn't love. But he does not
give a man except to those whom
he loves. So if you are a
person who believes in Allah in
the last day, you have faith in
Allah. You believe. Even if
that belief at this point in
time is weak. We go through
times of weakness, all of us.
It's not just that you Amen.
Rises and it never comes down.
No. That's not how it works. It
is fluctuates. It goes up with
obedience and it goes down with
disobedience. And since we are
inherently by nature,
disobedient creatures of Allah,
our imam is going to fluctuate.
It will happen.
When Iman
[Silence]
weak faith, there's good in
that person and the prophet
mentioned that the believer is
most what type of tree Who
knows?
What type of tree is the
believer? The palm tree.
and the palm tree, it has an
interesting thing about it. And
that is that if you do not
benefit from it, you can't be
harmed by it. That's what the
interesting thing about the is.
The least of its existence is
that it's not harmful. Doesn't
have spikes on it, doesn't have
thorns, doesn't have poison,
doesn't have poisonous fruit,
even a dead palm tree is
beneficial in some way. This is
why the prophet mentioned that
the believer is most the
date poem. Every aspect of the
believer is something that you
can be benefited from But the
least case scenario. The most
decrepit of palm trees. If it
doesn't benefit you it will not
harm you. This is not harmful.
Even a dead palm tree has some
benefit to it. And so Some of
these things are from Allah.
Some of these things are from
your actions but ultimately,
guidance comes from Allah Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala handpicks
and chooses specifically who he
wishes to guide to Islam. Now,
is this based on the person's
actions and the person's past
and the person's behavior? Yes,
it's based on that as well.
Right? Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala will misguide a person
or let a person become
misguided because of their
actions. And likewise, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala will guide
a person to Islam because of
his actions. Right? And so,
this is something that is from
Allah. The third thing that
will cause a person's heart to
become more and more open to
the Quran and Sunnah. If not
says
the third thing is beneficial
knowledge. What is beneficial
knowledge? It is knowledge that
has been inherited from the
prophet Muhammad
Knowledge of the Quran and
Sunnah. Knowledge of the wisdom
of the Quran and Sunna.
Knowledge of the secrets of the
Quran and Sunnah that only come
with great great concentration
and contemplation and
meditation. This is something
that will increase a person's
faith. That will increase a
person's faith. I could give an
example right now. I could pull
any verse from the Quran.
Anyone right now. And
contemplate it with you all.
And we could all meditate on
this verse and speak about all
of the different aspects of
this verse. And you will leave
here as if you are a new man.
Yes, that is what the Quran
does to the person. And if next
week we came, he, if next week
we came and sat down and
contemplated the same verse,
we're going to leave his new
men again. Do you know why?
Because that verse is not the
same again, the second time.
And we are not the same again,
the second time we hear it. And
that is why one of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala's names is
Alhai. The living, right? The
one of eternal absolute life.
And the Quran are are is a
collection of his words. And so
the Quran has this description.
That it is alive. You
understand? Subhan Allah. That
when a person reads the Quran,
it interact with him right?
There's an interaction that
takes place between the Quran
and the heart and you know, how
many verses of the Quran
subhanallah have we read many
times or we have memorized. I'm
sure there's verses of the
Quran right now that we've
memorized, that we don't know
even what they mean. but if we
were to learn what they mean,
we are to contemplate them
deeply and meditate on their
meanings, This would increase
our faith in Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. and really when we look
at something the Quran, we
look at something the sun
of the prophet we have some
people who look for miracles of
the Quran. We see this, right?
People that look for miracles
of the Quran scientific
miracles Allah said this
and this is not possible that
he could have said this and and
so on and so forth, right? Some
of these things are acceptable,
right? And clear and some of
these things are really
reaching and they're not really
on point with what Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala is actually
saying. They're reaching too
far, right? And they're making
the verse, they're bending it
and twisting its meaning. To
me, it's something that Allah
never intended. However, This
is not really the greatest
aspect of the Quran. And this
is not the greatest aspect that
will cause you to be strong in
faith. Usually, people who
follow this methodology where
I'm looking for verses that
click with my mind. Usually,
their faith is not very strong
and you will see that they are
people that do not follow the
prophet very closely and they
don't know him very well.
right?
However, what is the greater
miracle of the Quran? What will
really instill faith into your
heart that cannot be shaken is
when you read the Quran. Learn
it, memorize it if possible.
But understand it, and compare
it to itself.
right? Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala said
Quran
He said Allah do they not
contemplate the Qu
[Silence]
at first glance. What does this
verse have to do with this
verse? Why is this chapter
before this chapter, right? It
seems to be scattered but when
you look really deeply and you
have a relationship with the
Quran and I'm not talking about
two or three days, I'm not
talking about six months. I'm
talking about 10 and 20 and 30
years. When you start to see
how the Quran fits together
perfectly. So perfectly that if
one letter were to be removed,
it would change the meanings.
Of other chapters of the Quran.
That is what will really
instill faith in a person's
heart. Because that can't be
explained. You can't explain
that away. No matter what
anyone tells you after that,
that is your miracle. This is
the Quran. This is the sunnah.
There is no discrepancy between
the two. There is no
discrepancy between the Quran
and an authentic narration of
the prophet. It's impossible to
find. None. zero As a matter of
fact, used to say, I challenge
anyone to bring me two
narrations that seemingly
contradict and I will harmonize
them. Right? There is no
contradiction in the Quran.
There is no contradiction in
the sunnah of the prophet and
when you look at the Quran and
you compare it to itself, is no
book on this earth that can
intrude into your heart and can
bring out the best in you and
push away the worst of you like
the book of Allah, the Quran.
It is absolute truth. There's
no sugarcoating. There's no,
it's very clear. It's very
straightforward. And honestly,
one of the biggest things that
we have that is caused us to
stray from Islam is our
disconnection from the Quran.
And I'm gonna explain how that
disconnection is. Okay? Before
I do, I'm very very thirsty.
Please bring me a a bottle of
water. Just have a seat. They
hear me. Please bring me a
bottle of water. I'm gonna if I
had dentures, they'd be coming
out right now. Okay. I feel
like
Alright. So, I'm going to tell
you something very interesting
about the Quran. And something
very interesting about the way
that we have been separated
from the Quran. It's
interesting how we've been
separated from the Quran. As
Muslims. Okay?
and this is absolutely my
fault. I should have brought it
with me when I came up here.
There we go. When it rains, it
pours. Okay. Now, I got so much
water. I'm gonna I Elmedek. So,
how have we we've been
separated from from the Quran?
I wanna ask you a question. I
want you to answer it honestly.
You don't have to be a
historian to answer this
question. Has there ever been a
time in the history of Islam?
From the time of the prophet
Muhammad until today. When the
Quran has been more accessible.
What I mean by accessible is
it's everywhere. Anyone can
have it at any moment. Has
there ever been a time when the
Quran is more available than it
is right now. No. And that's
from two aspects It's physical
availability and the ability of
people to read. and the prophet
mentioned two things that are
the sign of the hour. Imagine
this with me. Literacy will
become common place and
ignorance
rise up and descend upon the
people. Isn't that seem to
contradict? Shouldn't literacy
make you more intelligent, more
knowledgeable, but that's not
what's gonna happen. The
prophet and I attainment
killer had
[Silence]
literacy will become common
place Everyone will know how to
read and write. It will be rare
to find someone who is
illiterate near the end of
time.
time of the prophet in the time
of the prophet
writing and spelling was was a
gift. That's something you had
to go abroad. You had to leave
Mecca. Leave Medina to go learn
it. And come back and bring it
to your people. and people that
could read and write were an
asset. It was three or
four in the whole city right?
And this is why Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala prohibited people who
were gifted with the ability to
write, that they not withhold
that gift and hold people
ransom to try to extort them
with that gift.
but at the same time, they had
wisdom that is very hard to
find today. At least they had
common sense, right? They had
common sense. To the point that
the prophet said in a
narration, indeed, in the
poetry of the Arabs, there is
wisdom. We're speaking about
prehistoric, pre-Islamic,
poetry. He said, there is
wisdom in it. Doesn't mean that
all of it is wisdom but there
is a lot of wisdom in it.
Today, we have an opposite
phenomenon going on Today,
everyone knows how to read and
write. Everyone You've probably
never met someone who doesn't
know how to read and write.
Unless you're very very old and
you know your grandmother from
right? However, another sign of
the hour is that as people
learn to read and write, an
increase of ignorance will come
about and knowledge will be
lifted from the earth. This is
what the prophet said,
knowledge will be taken away
and
ignorance will descend upon.
Mankind.
but this seems to be
contradictory. because if you
have the key to read all of the
books and all of the works of
the ancients, the ancient
scholars of Islam, if you are
able to open a book and read it
and learn on your own. It
should be that we are the most
knowledgeable of generations
but instead, we are the
opposite This is one of the
most ignorant and dark
generations. In Islamic history
why? Because We have changed
our direction Most of what is
available to read and write is
not positive or beneficial. and
so we turn on the phone and we
watch what? Ducks playing the
piano and we watch people
jumping over camels and we
watch people holding snakes and
people wearing glasses and
getting bit by snakes in the
face and we watch people ride
their bike off of mountains and
we watch people ride
skateboards on on on
skyscrapers and we watch and
this is entertaining to us. We
love this, right? and we say, I
have Facebook because I learn
things on Facebook. I learn
things from the Quran and the
Sunnah. Subhan Allah. The Quran
is right there. You can read
the whole thing. You don't have
to go through Facebook to do
it. And you know what? Is right
back there, right there. You
could go by it right now. And
you can read it for free. And
everything in it is correct.
And by the end of your reading,
you're gonna know the prophet
better than you know your own
children. But when we put the
prophet words and you know,
this it's kind of ironic
because this right here is
being streamed on Facebook,
right? This class right here.
huh. So, it's ironic, isn't
it? But it's this is the
only way we can get to people
now because if it's not in
their phone, it doesn't exist.
That's how it is now. right?
And so,
The thing is, is that,
putting the words of Allah, the
words of the prophet. Imagine
if you were to go to a bar or
go to a strip club and at the
back of the bar or the strip
club, you set up a a booth to
give Daw about Islam. Could you
imagine that with me? It's the
same thing. When you have a Daw
Corner and Instagram for me to
find you and get through all of
that. I gotta go through all
the strip club to get there to
you.
and so, it's very hard to reach
the Quran in now. The reason
is, is being competed with.
We've been separated from the
Quran and that's why our hearts
become dark. If you don't have
the Quran in your heart, you
have darkness in your heart.
That's how it works. There's a
narration. It's it's got
weakness in its chain of
narrations and his chain of
narration but his meaning is
correct on the authority of
heaven, Abbez, and
Quran. It said the heart which
contains nothing of the Quran
is a, is an abandoned
house. It has nothing in it.
It could facilitate people but
it's not okay. It's not been
upkept. So, it's it's it's just
a place where vagabonds and you
know,
crackheads and people go to do
illicit things. That's where
that's what the heart becomes.
Because it was built for a
reason but the the purpose it
was built for is not is not
being used for that. So it will
be used and abused by everyone
else. When we think about this
is an interesting statement A a
heart that does not contain the
Quran is an abandoned
house. Right? What takes place
in abandoning abandoned
buildings? Tell me. Huh? Drug
use? Zena. People hiding from
the law. Right? Yeah.
vagabonds, people that are just
drifters, the riff raft, drug
use, you know, dead bodies are
hidden there. Weapons are
hidden there. That's what it
becomes. So, this this parable
is very interesting. A heart
that does not contain the Quran
is an abandoned building.
Subhan Allah. And so,
How have we been separated from
the Quran? Is there anyone here
or anyone listening that
doesn't have access to the
Quran on his phone? I don't
know about these Apple watches.
Can you even read the Quran on
your Apple Watch? I don't know,
maybe, right? The only thing
left is for me to give you
glasses to put on with the
Quran in your eyes. What is
left? It's there, it's
available, it's there for
everyone but why don't we read
it? There's a few reasons why
we don't read it. but the
biggest reason why we don't
read it is because we are
afraid of it.
We're afraid of the Quran. Why
are we afraid of it? What do
you mean? I'm Muslim. How can I
be afraid of the Quran? Because
the Quran demands change. When
you read the Quran, it demands
that you change your ways. And
we don't change. I'm
comfortable. I'm happy how I
am. I don't wanna change
anything. I don't wanna change
my habits. I'm happy now. But
the Quran demands that you
change. You have to change the
way you think. You have to
change the way you speak. You
have to change the way you
talk. You have to change the
way you walk. You have to
change the way you dress. You
have to change the way you
treat people. And we don't like
that. That makes us
uncomfortable
So, we learn ways to make
ourselves feel we're
giving the Quran. It's do right
but actually we are ignoring
it. How do we do that? we
read the Quran in Arabic and we
don't understand Arabic. That's
it. That's one way. Well, I
read the Quran every month one
time. Do you know Arabic? Do
you understand it? I don't
understand a thing but I read
it every month.
Jamir. What what was the point
of that? Of that exercise? Yes,
you get We we understand that.
You get rewarded. It's good. I
I understand it's good. I'm not
saying that's bad but I'm
saying what is the purpose of
the Quran? Is it to read or is
it to understand what's the
purpose of the Quran?
Allah said he we have sent down
the book in order that the
people meditate and contemplate
its meanings and verses. That's
the point of the Quran. So if
you're just reading it without
knowing what it says, without
understanding it, you're just
doing some exercise. Yes,
you're be given and yes, you
will see the result of this in
your life but your heart is not
changing. It's the mean that
change the heart
one verse of the Quran is so
potent that if you contemplate
it seriously and you learn its
secrets, it's a potent dye
that is plate dropped into a
glass of water. It will change
it. It'll never go back to
being the same. This is why
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
referred to his religion as we
know this verse. Law.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
this, I want you to listen to
this verse. Listen to this
verse. Let's let's spend the
rest of these 8 minutes
contemplating this verse in
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
about his religion and about
the Quran. It is the die of
Allah. the what is die? What do
I mean by die? Die. Die that
dyes your clothes. You dye your
clothes with. Color. Color.
Right? Die. We understand what
die means. It is the die of
Allah.
What does that mean to die of
Allah?
When die comes in contact with
fabric okay? Can you ever get
it out? You can never get it
out and leave that that fabric
the same way it was. You can
never get it out. It will be
there permanently. And this is
the meaning of Allah. If we
look in the same chapter, think
about this. In the same
chapter,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
about the worship of the calf.
They said,
that the people of they
saturated their hearts with the
worship of the of the calf.
Then, he says, the Quran and
Islam is the die of Allah.
Notice the two things here. The
Quran is natural. the worship
of other than Allah is
unnatural. okay? What am I
getting at here? That if a
verse of the Quran, if you hear
it and you understand it
completely with your heart,
whether you accept it or not,
it changes you and you'll never
be the same again. You will
never be the same again. No
matter how short that verse is.
Even it's Even if the verses
even if the verse is
even if the verse is one verse
The condition is that you
understand it. If you hear it
and understand it properly and
you contemplate it, even a non
Muslim, even Abu Jahid could
not get it out of his heart
after that. Do you know that
Abu Jahid? We know who Abu
Jahil is, right? Do you know
the prophet used to go every
night to pray at the Kaaba
every night. You pray
and
he would recite the Quran.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says recite the Quran in a
medium voice. Not too high and
not too low. Medium. Abujail
used to sneak out of his house
at night. every night and hide
behind thee, behind the curtain
that covers the Kaaba and
listen to the Quran all night
long. and when he would see
that is about to come out, he
would scurry away a
cockroach back to his home.
He was absolutely captivated by
the Quran. He could not get it
out of his mind. His problem
was was he was too arrogant.
That's what prevented him from
following Abuja Hill was
narrated to have said we know
that Mohammed is the messenger
of Allah.
but he did not come from our
tribe. And our tribe and Benny
Hashim, the tribe of the
prophet have always been in
competition. They gave charity,
we gave charity. They freed
slaves. we freed, we freed
slaves. They observed bravery,
we were braver, braver than
them. And we continued two
race horses. Neck to neck. And
then all of the sudden Benny
Hashem comes and says, we have
a prophet who receives
revelation from Allah. How are
we gonna compete with that? He
said, well, he we will never
follow him. Those are the words
of Abu Jahal.
and so, not even Abu Jahih
could get the Quran out of his
heart. Once he heard a verse,
it changed him. changed them
permanently just die when
it touches fabric. It changes
it permanently. You can't get
it out of your heart. You'll
never be the same person again.
That scares us. And so we as
Muslims, yes, I'm saying we as
Muslims. we find ways to avoid
the Quran. Because we're afraid
of the intrusiveness of the
Quran. We're afraid of the
change that it demands. We're
afraid of what it's going to do
to us. and that's why Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says
Oh you who have believed, enter
into Islam completely, not half
heartedly. Not one foot in
Islam and one foot in the
dunya. Come in all the way.
That's what he said. because of
this issue Has the Quran ever
been more available in the
history of Islam than it is
today? What's the answer?
Answer, answer. What's the
answer? Has it ever been more
available than it is today? Has
it ever been more have has the
Muslim ummah ever been more
unacquainted and ignorant of
the Quran
That's a historical fact You
know, in the time of the
Ottoman Empire, it was
mentioned that the average
diction, meaning the average
vocabulary of a twelve-year-old
in the time of the Ottoman
Empire was fifty thousand
words. That's just 100 years
ago. You know why? Because it
was standard that every child
was memorized the Quran and
memorized bin Malik.
Therefore vocabulary was fifty
thousand words. While in
Britain it was around 15, 000
words. That was their
vocabulary. I don't even have
that vocabulary. I don't think.
That was the average vocabulary
of a 12 year old. Just 150
years ago. We will continue
this topic inshallah next week.
before we finish, I want to
make sure that every everyone
understands that when I speak
forcefully and I speak about
these issues, kinda touchy
issues. I'm not attacking
anyone and I'm not saying that
I do this and you guys don't.
No, I'm speaking about us
together. Collectively. This is
a problem all of us. So, I hope
that noone takes this in the
wrong way.
Inshallah,